[Music]
welcome back to the true Jordie podcast
today I am joined by a man who Mike
tison described as the toughest white
man on the planet it's Big Joe Egan
thanks for coming bro it's a pleasure
Brian thank you for having me on your
show and uh do me research about you I
uh you know I see Tyson speak of you
very highly you obviously also fought
Lennox Lewis you're a Irish boxing
champion and now you're looking to fight
Big John Fury
how did that come about man well John's
challenged any 58y old on the planet
that's brave enough game enough to get
into the ring with him and I've been
listening to this and I thought well I'm
brave enough I'm game enough and I've
responded to his challenge we've seen
him recently sort of like having a go at
call Frampton after call Frampton said
uh you know I think that Jake Paul might
beat Tommy Fury for example and and and
other moments he's had around YouTubers
what do you make of of the way John's
sort of uh I guess promoting himself now
KL Frampton voiced his opinion and for
John to stand over him trying to
intimidate him trying to bully him a
two-time champion of the world a
man half his less than half his size was
very very
disrespectful and I think
that in boxing is a great camaraderie
and boxing teaches you first and
foremost self-respect and respect for
others John Fury showed car framp in no
respect that night and it was wrong it
was very
disrespectful it's disrespectful to any
person to conduct yourself like that but
especially to a two-time champion of the
world who knows he's boxing I mean he
was right at the end of the day it was a
close fight and and Jake Paul did put
Tommy Fury down at one point so it
wasn't that far off do you know what I
mean to be fair to the block and uh yeah
I I think a lot of people will be
interested to see how John responds to
you because it's one thing doing that to
a much smaller man you on the other hand
it's a whole another ball game right
because you're cut from a similar cloth
you and John are fighting men and you're
big men and you are in your late 50s uh
how do you think the body is held up and
and and do you feel like you're ready to
go if this fight gets made I've looked
after myself to a certain
degree and I believe that my chin is
better than John Fury's my chin has been
hit by Mike Tyson by Lenox Lewis and by
Bruce Eldon three heavyweight champions
of the world and they didn't put me down
John was hit by Henry Aken one day and
he was put to sleep so one world
champion hit him one heavyweight world
champion so I think my chin is still
Rock Solid even at 58 it will still be
as rock SED as what it was what it was
at
28 whether my hand speed will be as good
as when it was 28 whether my footwork
would be as good as when I was 28 but I
know my chin would be still as good the
good news is uh I've spoken to Ms Taylor
the uh the owner and obviously promoter
of Misfit boxing and he is head without
doubt he's going to make an offer to you
I'm Big John Fury so we will have the
promotion the venue the money on the
table there is no reason why if Big John
Fury thinks he is the guy the best guy
in the world at 58 59 years old whatever
it is that he doesn't make this fight
happen if he wants to prove it do you
know what I mean cuz it's all going to
be there for you I was in the company of
Ms the other night at KSI at the Misfits
boxing tournament in Le it was
incredible there was some great fights
there was a fantastic atmosphere and the
hospitality that I was shown and the
friendship that I was given on the night
I would love to work with them people I
think they're doing a wonderful job for
boxing I've be asked been asked many
many times what do I think of the
YouTube boxing and I say it's exposure
for boxing because these YouTubers are
are into hundreds of millions and they
might not necessarily watch Boxing on an
everyday occasion but if they look at it
on the YouTube and they suddenly think I
like that sport 100 million fans and you
get 1% of that 100 million fans that's 1
million new fans that boxing is gained I
love boxing I LIF for boxing I'm an next
boxer I'm now a fan I think the sport is
blossoming with the YouTubers I'm glad
you think so me CU like like you like I
just want to see young kids getting
interested in boxing learning how to
defend themselves it gets you so much
more self-respect and you know people
like yourself who you were bullied when
you were a kid and you you know that's
what gets you to to learn the ropes and
learn how to defend yourself and feel
better about yourself I only ever had
the one to Knocked Down in box and I got
two t knocked out by the bullies when I
was seven or eight years of age in
Manchester when I made my Holy
Communion the two bully boys who were 15
or 16 they tried to take my Holy
Communion meddle and I held on to my
medle on my waist coat and exposed my
front teeth and then knocked out my two
front teeth I got bullied as a child
when I came to the UK to visit my dad
who was working on the building sites
over here like a lot of Irish we came to
the UK to work and we came to visit my
dad who was working here and I got
bullied because I had the Irish accent
so I picked up the English accent and
when I went home to Dublin I got bullied
in Dublin because I had the English
accent I got batted by the bullies I've
got four younger sisters and two younger
brothers I'm the eldest of seven so when
the bullies would finish beating on me
rather than them hit them I would jump
back in and say don't hit them hit me
more even now talking about it it was it
was um it was a hard time growing up the
boxing ring was actually quite safe for
me Brian there was only one man hitting
me even if it was Mike Tyson or Lenox
Lewis it was only one man MH at a
referee you had a break in between
rounds you had Medical Care at ringside
if you got sever hurt I never had that
luxury get bed by the
bullies and you know John specifically
you obviously were around at the same
time as John what did you make of John
as a fighter back then John like all
fighters is a tough person you've got to
be tough you know you play soccer you
play basketball you play golf you play
football you don't play boxing it's a
contact sport you don't play it it's not
a game John was a fighter that was born
with courage and toughness he would have
had hard times as a pro the same as I
had hard times as a pro we wouldn't have
had the luxury of 12 and 10 and 14 week
training camps to prepare John would
have worked on a building site all day
and then gone to fight on the night I
worked three jobs as a pro I worked the
door in a pub I worked the door in a
nightclub and I worked in Dublin Airport
for Delta Airlines and I used to sleep
for a couple of hours in an armchair my
dad would wake me up I so tired am I
going to the gym am I going to work what
job am I doing and I never really had
the proper preparation as a pro the same
as what John would have suffered in the
same way not having the proper
preparation and as an old saying failed
to prepare be prepared to fail so we
never fulfilled any true potential that
we would have had if this fight's made
and me and John get a a 12 or a 14 we
training camp whatever's left in our
tank we will bring out the best of
what's left and I know two proud men
we'll give a good fight we'll give a
good account of ourselves you know he's
not going to bow down to me I'm not
going to bow down to him the best man
will win on the night M I'm hoping it's
me I believe it can be
me let's find out let's get the fight
mate I think it would be electric mate
he are both good talkers you're both
very entertaining people and also you
know I'm misfitz recently we we recently
had one of the Gladiator Lads Rhino I
thought I thought uh kton Headley as the
Gladiator Raider yeah I thought car know
I love the Gladiator yeah well seeing
one of like I'll be honest uh the the
two guys who fought uh not this SMI F
gone but the one before I think late 40s
early 50s the and they put on a great
fight it was one of the most
entertaining fights of the night let
alone two big men like yourself who can
still pack a punch because the power is
the last thing to go and um and and John
obviously you know he's he's he's got
loads of kids who are boxers he's he's
literally bred a load of boxers yeah so
he knows what he's doing in that ring in
terms of skills you've watched John
fight where where do you rank your
skills versus John's I wasn't very
skillful I don't think John was very
skillful either we just tough men um
what we lacked in skill we showed in
heart and courage MH I do believe it
will be a good fight the thing is Right
none of us can beat Father Time Father
Time catches up on us all mhm to have a
reason to train we can help slow far the
time
down this is a good reason for me to
train yeah and it's a good reason for
John to train because sometimes when
you're punching a bag you're on a cross
trainer or you're running on on the road
after all the years of doing it it does
get a bit monotonous and you need that
uh you need that challenge it's like one
of the last Rocky movies you know when
he came back well rocky rocky is
actually based on a true story as you
know um with the um choke webner yeah
the Bayon bleeder and there was a lot of
I dinner with sester salom which was
incredible sit Talking To The Man He's a
massive boxing fan and there's so many
truths in there films because he would
have done his history he would have done
his studying he would have done his due
diligence on boxes and what they have to
endure and what they have to go through
and um sometimes when they make the
comeback they make the comeback for the
wrong reason they make the comeback
because they need the money and you see
men that were champions of the world you
know having fortunes at their disposal
and then suddenly end up penniless and
having to make a comeback because they
need the money have to is a horrible
master and when
i' done it when I made my first comeback
this isn't my first comeback I made my
first comeback when when I came out of
prison and I was broke and I hadn't
boxed in 12 years and I didn't know what
to do I was to a convict and i' made my
dad
ashamed sorry
man the only time I ever saw my daddy
cry was when his dad died
and when I got sent to
prison I watched my dad
cry I felt
sick and
ashamed so when I come out of prison I
made a
comeback because
who take your time bro it's all good oh
we want want to do in
life is make our parents
proud so when I come out of prison I
made a
comeback after 12 years and it said it
in the boxing news George Foreman makes
the comeback after 10 years Big Joe
Eagan makes the come back after 12 years
to get mentioned in the same paragraph
As George Foreman one of the greatest
heavyweight champions of the world was
incredible but it was broke
and I needed the money and I didn't want
to get into trouble again I didn't want
to shame myself again in front of my dad
so I don't want to all I know how to do
is fight and and I won in the fifth
round and it was an incredible
experience the fear I went through on
the night sitting in the dressing
room was was I'd forgotten what it was
12 years is a long time long time out of
the ring and I want won in the fifth
round and it was an incredible
experience I got myself a lot of money
and I was hoping to have another fight
and I went
training to spar for another fight that
with a friend of mine that had sparred
with many times a guy called Steve
Dawson a good light heavyweight head G
up we're leaving the house before we
went sparring we leaving the house and
his little boy Tristan said what are he
doing Big Joe I I'm going sparing with a
daddy Tristan what we've done many many
years for many years is and he said
who's the toughest Tristan and I said oh
your daddy's the toughest man on the
planet like in old boy eyes the dad's
the toughest man in the planet uhhuh so
he goes really Joe I said yeah your
dad's the toughest man on the planet
Tristan and we went sparring like I done
many many times with Steve before I
ducked into a a punch with the head gear
on and it caught my eye and it split my
eye open and I felt the blood running
down my
face and it wasn't the best punch that
stay had ever Hur me with before it
wasn't the best point that I'd ever been
hit with before but he just caught me on
the bone and ripped my eye wide open a
bad place to got hit in it I knew then
it was over I knew then it was over I
was 38 years of age and I knew it was
over I went to the hospital I got all
the stitches in my face went back to
Tristan's house went back to Steve's
house and Tristan was looking at my
busted eye and he said what happened to
your eye Big Joe I said oh your daddy
caught me when we were sparing he said
you said he was the toughest man on the
planet ins to injury but that was 20
years ago people are asking me about
this fight with John and I said listen I
haven't cycled a bike on the streets for
20 years but I know I could go on to a
bicycle and cycle around the streets of
Birmingham or any City in the UK I'm not
going to win the Tour to
France the same as the boxing I on my
way around the boxing ring 20 years out
of the ring same as John knows his way
around the boxing ring and we will give
a good account of ourselves but it back
then there was a different goal right
you wanted to make your dad proud yes
you also still you know were're fairly
young you know to make it come back what
38 or something like that 38 yeah so and
I needed the money Bryant exactly so
what is the motivation behind this one I
still believe I can rise to this
challenge of John Fury throwing the
corner down to any man brave enough to
step into the ring with him is that a
word that motivates you bravery oh yeah
I feel like it is because not many
people want to SP Mike Tyson especially
not as long as you did I needed the
money when I sparing Mike as well
because when I was in America what I was
earning with Mike I was shipping home to
my family ah and the money help shape my
brothers and sisters lives so the longer
I lasted with Mike the more money I
earned the more money I earned to
benefited my family more I just think
that I like this challenge he's been a
little bit disrespectful to a lot of
these YouTubers which I don't think is
nice you know these are a young fan base
these are young young young young adults
you mean in the press conferences where
he's sort of starting on them in that
boxing doesn't just need great Fighters
it needs great ambassadors mhm I don't
think John is conducting himself well as
an ambassador his son is one of the
greatest heavyweight champions of all
time I really do believe that I think
Tyson Fury could hold his own in any era
he's got incredible hand speed he's got
incredible movement he's got a great
chin he's got a great heart he's massive
as well he's a big Powerhouse of a man
but his stamina levels are incredible
for a heavyweight he could when he
fought Wilder and he got put down in
that last
round and he got up now when you get put
down you're told to take the count and
then when you get up you're told to hold
on and try and get your composure I've
held on many many times you know
sometimes when I was hit that hard by
different opponents I would hold on that
tight you couldn't get me off them with
a crowbar I would hold on that tight
just to get head together yes right
Tyson Fury done what I've never seen
before put it on him didn't he he put it
on him and I think Wilder didn't expect
that no one expected it you know so John
he doesn't say it in the nice way about
his children I don't think he says the
the the nice way of saying it that's his
son that's the heavyweight champion of
the world that's his DNA that's his
flesh and blood and he's a credit to his
dad
John isn't a credit to PO with his
conduct isn't the credit to boxing with
his attitude isn't a credit to boxing
with what he says and it's a shame
really because he signs a a bad light on
his son one one thing I do believe that
when John was in prison and Tyson signed
his contract early in his career he
signed with mck Hennessy now Tyson could
have signed a contract with Sky Sports
with a manager to that Sky Sports but
instead he signed with mck Hennessy and
I believe the reason he signed with
mckeny was because mck Hennessy had to
deal with Channel 5 so he's Dad could
watch him in prison on his TV in his
prison cell and he probably cost himself
a lot of money by signing a particular
deal with Mick that he could have signed
with maybe a bigger promoter so his dad
could watch him so I know that they have
a great relationship sometimes father
and son's relationships are tested MH
you know true love never runs smooth
yeah tell us about it you know so but at
the end of the day I know Tyson would
want to do his father proud like any son
wants to do I believe that he has not
only has he just done his father proud
he's done boxing proud with his
achievements every fighter that climbs
into the ring dreams about becoming a
champion of the world I wasn't good
enough nowhere near good enough I won
Irish titles which was a major
achievement for me but you were good
though and I was I wasn't I was okay the
reason I'm saying this though is because
when I went on um do you know py do oh
yeah right so obvious man exactly very
legendary traveling you know pad's an
incredible guy and a good friend of mine
my mom's people are horse people all
right you know so five four five
generations back my mom's family used to
Le show horses well he thought you were
a traveler my mom people my mom's people
were horse people all right and uh one
of my grand grand grand uncles giggin
Riley M's a Riley used to Le show horses
toout the Guinness when horses was the
we all right my family used to Le sh
horses to the in so one of my family
members Maybe more of my family members
could boast that Artic inis was a family
friend now I don't drink alcohol I'm an
Irish man that doesn't drink alcohol
people say what sort of an Irish man are
you you don't drink alcohol and my dad
used to say he's a failure as an Irish
man expected of Patty to drink but I've
have no interest in alcohol but paty do
he talked about your fight by the way
with John and he said ironically you
mentioned horses earlier cuz he said
you're both thoroughbreds you're both
Thoroughbred men and everyone in the
comments was saying Big John won't want
to fight him because he's a real test
for any man at that age especially so
you've got a lot of respect in this
boxing Community mate and uh you know
par do is uh you know big name in his
own right and he certainly believed that
it would be a great fight so the
appetite is there without a doubt and um
and a lot of this is is from your
background right so let's talk about the
the early days because for me I'm a
massive Mike Tyson fan and um for for
you to be on your way over there it's
such a young how old were you when you
17 sorry so you're on your way to
America at 17 and you're going to fight
this guy Mike Tyson or spar with him
rather no I wasn't going to spar Mike I
went on the Irish team I went on the
Irish team to box in America and I got
batted um in Atlantic City he got
pounded to a pulp by a big American big
American Sergeant he was 28 Jesus I was
I was big for me I was on the doors I
left school when I was 14 years of age I
was on the doors of nightclubs when I
was 15 and I left school with two
swimming certificates I don't read or
right so good and I really believed that
I'm going to make my fortune out of
boxing and I didn't think I need
pitagoras as theum or anything like that
from school you know so I um went to
America on the Irish team gave an
account to myself the best I could do
cuz that's all we can do is try our best
in anything that we do is to try our
best and I tried my best my best wasn't
good enough the marine sergeant was too
big too strong and he bothered me that's
mental that you were in there with a
28-year-old are 17 though that is crazy
but I've been fighting grown men as a as
as as as as a young boy anyway you know
sparing with grown men fighting young
older men and um I could take it beating
like I said earlier on get battered by
the bullies toughened me up for the
beatings and I took this beating of this
marine sergeant and Floyd Patterson was
in attendance his wife was Irish and he
took a great interest in the Irish team
there was an Irish feder called PA
fitgerald and incredible fight he won he
got the opportunity to stay on and Floyd
Patterson gave me the opportunity to
stay on so whatever I did to impress the
man wouldn't have been skills but I
think he he he he he he admired my
courage and my toughness and he gave me
the opportunity to stay in America and
he brought me to Gleason's gym and I
spared a couple of pro heavyweight in
Gleason's gym I Tucker I can't remember
the other heavyweights name but Al Gavin
and Bob Jackson were there and they they
done an original deal with C on a gym so
they that's custom M for those who don't
know yeah the great man himself
incredible man yeah an incredible man
and uh they gave me the the the chance
to go to the cat skills they said
there's a young heavyweight in the cat
skills called Mike Tyson 17 years of age
and they're looking for sparing Partners
I'd never heard of Mike I'd come over
from Ireland I didn't know who this boy
was he was knocking Men Out Left Right
and Cent I didn't know this and now a
word from our sponsors I'm sure you've
heard of CBD before it's fantastic STI
and I'm going to tell you why I've added
it to my daily routine this is a natural
compound found inside the cannabis plant
but before some of you panic it's
completely legal and it isn't going to
get you high now some of the main
reasons are it helps me with my sleeping
Stress and Anxiety and after hearing
that I'm pretty sure you can all do with
a bit of CBD I've read the comments you
lot seem stressed every time you want to
insult me just take one of these bad
boys it'll calm you right down there's a
reason why this box is basically nearly
finished cuz I've been having plenty of
these responsibly cuz you know you don't
want to overdo it but just to prove do
love
these
lovely I'm I'm fine I'm fine no more
stress and anxiety now so wonderful
you've also got this wonderful Sab oil I
like to take a little drop under the
tongue like
so just before bed if I want a really
good night's sleep and you've also got
these face creams which I've seen do
amazing things for people with skin
conditions it's unbelievable how good
they work Supreme CBD are without doubt
the market leader in this field you will
get the best quality products you can
find and I've got an unbelievable
discount for you guys with
40% off when you use my code which is
true 40 that's old block capitals t u E4
at checkout you can click the link in
the description below get yourself there
get whatever you want and thank me later
so big thanks to Supreme CBD for helping
us with our stress anxiety with sleep
but most of all for sponsoring the
channel but for now enjoy the video I
was just happy to hear he was the same
age so when we got to the cat skills oh
Brian when we got to the cat skills and
I was introduced to C and to Camille and
to Manny and to Tom and to Jay and to
everybody else that was there it was an
incredible warm welcome and it was like
a home from home at that instance I just
fell in love with the place and then I
met Mike and he was so welcoming as
well and I looked at him and I thought
he's smaller than me and it turned out
he was several months younger than
me and I thought I'm going to B you but
I didn't know what he was
doing as a boxer at that stage of his
life you know he was knocking Men Out
Left Right and center and we became
instant friends talking about Barry
mcgan because he had a fascination with
Barry and the relationship that Barry
had with Mr Eastwood who were ni signed
professional I signed with Mr Eastwood
as well but Mike had this fascination
with Barry and Mr Eastwood as like a
father and son relationship like what he
had with cus he was also fascinated
about the history of Irish boxing Mike
was like a walking Encyclopedia of
boxing and we just hit it off instantly
we walked talked watched film footage
that night and I really got to like him
and I thought I'm going to have to B to
you inspireing tomorrow I really
believed that I had the measure of him
next morning me and him were went
jogging um Jed for about a mile and he
took off like a gazelle he was an
incredible Runner and I just thought
thought yeah go on you tie yourself I'm
going to take it out on you later on in
the gym went back to the house relaxed
few hours then we travel in the mini bus
down the spa and suddenly all these big
powerhouses of men appear we were living
in the house they were living in anx and
I hadn't seen them and they were all
walking very somber but they knew what
was coming stupid Patty here didn't know
what was coming they had been sparing
them before yeah they knew what was
coming they knew the damage that was
coming they knew the pain that was
coming and I'm looking at these is
walking like men going to The Gallows
I'm getting on the mini bus with I'm
laughing I'm so relaxed I'm I'm very
confident because I've been fighting men
like I said that 28y old marine sergeant
so there's no way a 17y old boy is going
to hurt me like the men hurt me got to
the gym Shadow boxed C said bandage up
glove up get ready to spar and I'm
looking around and there's no sign of
mic and I look into the ring and he's
pacing the ring with his shirt off and
his body is incredible it's chest his
neck his biceps I hadn't seen him
stripped to the waist and there's no way
a 17-year- old boy should look like this
Powerhouse cus pointed to one of the big
powerful men to get in and he got
knocked spark out with the first punch
that landed and I tell people I'm not
ashamed to say I ruined a good pair of
Underpants at that moment that punch
landed I myself I thought oh my God
this 17y old boy has this power anyway
two more got in they got this patch
pretty quick I was number four I got
batted for 3 minutes but I got out I
stayed on my feet for the three minutes
and I got out couple more got in maybe I
took the thing out of Mike's punches but
he didn't dispatch the next couple that
quick and had a little bit of a rest
bite and I got in again I got batted
again I got batted for six minutes that
day but the madness in me because I do
believe the fighters have to have a bit
of Madness in them you
know the madness in me I thought I'm
going to get the better of you one day I
never did I stayed home with Mike for
two years and I very proud to say that I
stayed on my feet he hurt me made me cry
many
times but I stayed on my feet and what
that did for me it gave me the courage
and the confidence to believe because
psychological warfare in boxing is a big
part of the the sport you know and I
believe psychologically I believe that I
could take Mike Tyson's punches I could
take anybody's punches and even when I
got battered by Lenox Lewis and I did
get battered by Lenox Lewis it was an
honor to share the ring with Mike and
with Lenox they achieved what I dreamed
of
achieving but when I got batted by Lenox
my cornermen wanted to throw the
toweling and I said no I can take this
punishment and I stayed on my feet only
am much three rounds but he was knocking
everybody out mhm and I lost on
points but it was a great achievement
for me to stay on my feet with two of
the greatest heavyweights of all time
definitely of my era and of any era for
sure of any era yeah I believe they
could live in any era every yeah and to
be able to say all these years on that
we're still friends because that's what
boxing does it gives you a friendship
really that can stand the test of time
you know you exchange blows but when the
fight over you embrace it's nothing
really personal promoters try to make it
personal because they've got to sell the
fight you know but really deep down it
shouldn't be anything personal you know
there should be an admiration for your
opponent there should be a respect for
your
opponent and if you don't admire him and
you don't respect him you won't train
hard enough to fight him you've got to
respect him you've got to know that that
person M or female that's coming out of
that opposite corner is coming to do
damage to you MH you know they're going
to punch you with the best of their
ability so you've got to be prepared to
take them punches you've got to be fit
enough to go the distance at least
because a Fighter's pride stand up and
fight until we hear the Bell stand up
and fight fight like hell a Fighter's
Pride you want to hear that final Bell I
beg referees not to stop me when I was
caught to the Bone one fight I got 64
stitches I was caught across the top of
the eye down the side of the eye across
the cheek across this eye across the lip
Jesus 64 stitches after that fight and I
pleaded with the referee don't stop the
fight fifth round I got my tooth knocked
out in the first round and I got cut to
the Bone and I beg the referee please
don't stop the fight the referee's name
was Fred T he'd won the Olympic silver
medal in 1956 X Island and he was a
family friend he let his heart R his
head I I could
see but there was a lot of blood anyway
the fight was
stopped and I didn't want the fight to
be stopped I I was I was doing okay I
was just getting badly badly caught
anyway when when the fight was stopped I
went to the hospital I got internal
States and I was it was a blood bat but
my pride wanted me to hear a final Bell
my Tyson in his prime what does a power
punch feel like from
him I had head gear on and he had big
gloves on and the pain when he when he
when he lands that punch when he lands
that punch it's
like it's a bit of a numbing effect as
well he sort of numbs you but hurt you
at the same
time but um he was so quick and Powerful
speed people didn't give him the credit
for the speed but I wasn't really that
tall for heavyweight he hit a lot of the
big guys with the uppercuts and he
lifted them off the floor he'd be
spinning his hips around wouldn't he but
he his head movement people didn't give
him the credit for his skill people just
gave him the credit for his power cus
had him H to Perfection I don't believe
that we ever saw the best of Mike Tyson
when Mike launched my book in Canary
Warf which was one of the most
incredible days of my life I said in my
book The Best of Mike Tyson died when
cus died because we never saw the best
of Mike 20 years of age K had already
died when Mike won the world heavyweight
title and I think that that that
affected Mike because Fighters need
minding they need to be cared for they
need to be nurtured properly to bring
out the best of them they're quite
sensitive individuals actually a lot of
Fighters very very I found that out the
hard way once a lot of Fighters have the
similar stories bullied as kids if you
talk to most Fighters they've
experienced at some stage of their life
bullying
and most
Fighters outside of the ropes are quite
timid inside of the Rope when the bells
goes when the bell goes they fight and
that's what they're trying to do but
outside they're
Placid they're
polite and I think it's the greatest
boort in the world I think they're the
greatest athletes in the world but when
when K died we never saw the best of
Mike imagine what he could have done if
K had have lived a few more more
years did you have a talk to Mike about
his upbringing yeah we used to sit and
talk all the time yeah where Mike came
from in Brownsville in in New York I
lived in Bay Ridge in Brooklyn for a
while and I Old Brownsville Shannon
bricks came from Brownsville as well
Brownsville was a very very hard
district and Mike as a child had run the
streets of Brownsville as a little boy
yeah and he was arrested Lords listen he
was trying to fend for himself as a
little boy and he had really no proper
Parental Guidance he' no
um no love and affection as a child
should have really I don't MB Mike's
introduction into this world I'm going
to tell you a story now right I'll tell
you a story now separate to that but
still to do with that M Mike could spoke
to my mom on the phone for 22 years
never met her and this particular day he
said How's your mother doing Joe I said
she's not so good Mike I said she's a
lump removed from my neck and we're very
concerned that it's cancer my Uncle
Brian died of cancer at 47 he wasn't
even a smoker my mom was a smoker I've
lost my mom and dad now they went in
2022 got dressed them
MH but Mike said let's go and visit your
mom Joe so me Mike and Scott Welch
former British and Comm World
Heavyweight Champion he fought under
Tyson under card he fought Henry akam
one for 12 rounds we've landed in Dublin
to visit my mom who's recently being
released from hospital because of the
Lum REM remov from my neck there was the
MRSA book she couldn't stay in the
hospital so they put her to the care of
her sister my Auntie Linda so she's at
my auntie Linda's house this hysteria
Mike Tyson coming into
Dublin anyway we went to my's house Mike
met my mom for the first time after
speaking to her she used to thank Mike
for looking after me she oh Mike thank
you so much for looking after my son he
was Bing me week and week out but he
didn't know that he he was minding me
outside of the sparring City he cared
for me and she um spoke to him and he
embraced her he put his arms around her
and he held her and this is a man that
can break bones with punches embracing a
fragile woman it was beautiful to see
anyway they got talking about birthdays
my mom's birthday was the 12th of July
Mike's birthday's the 30th of June and
they're both of the same birth sign
Cancer
and Mike said Mrs Egan he said I
remember on my 18th birthday we were
together when we were 17 Mike so his
18th birthday would have been the first
birthday that my mother sent him a
present wow and he said I remember on my
18th birthday Mrs Egan he said you sent
over a shoe box with some potato chips
Irish T crisps some money in an envelope
it would have been very little money and
some sweatshirts there would have been
secondhand sweatshirts and that was 21
22 years previous and my mom said to
Mike you remember that Mike he said Mrs
Egan he said yes I remember it he says
very few people have given me anything
in my life yes I remember it Scott Welch
got choked up he had to leave the room I
broke down crying MH excuse the language
I don't curse very often I'm crying
Mike's embracing my Mom and Mike looked
at me and he goes Jo you
you're always crying and he made me cry
so many times I do cry a lot you
know um I'm an emotional character you
know same same and um it get worse you
get older doesn't it I feel like I cry
more and more every year mate that day
that day looking at a man that could
have been a billionaire athlete
remembering a couple of packets of
crisps a couple of pounds in an envelope
and a couple of secondhand sweatshirts
I don't envy what he had to Ure in his
life I envy his achievements in boxing
but I don't eny what he had to endure in
his
life yeah I mean it unfortunately while
we're on the subject of Mike's life it
it as often is the case when when
someone becomes the source of money as
you mentioned the amount of money he
earned he probably did have a billion
through his fingers at one one point or
another and but there was so many
leeches and toxic people around him and
um you know you had Don King for example
who wasn't uh great uh you know
allegedly in the way it's it's the
only sport in the world where the Lambs
rule the Lions you don't see boxing
promoters standing on doors of
nightclubs when their careers are
finished but yet you see heavyweight
champions of the world standing on doors
and nightclubs when the cre a finish Joe
Louie one the greatest of all time stood
on the door of a casino in Vegas Tony
TNT took a two-time heavyweight champion
of the world standing on a door in
Florida that's just two to mention you
know men that had Millions go through
their hands but the parasites the
promoters the managers that really
should wrap them in Cotton wool and
embrace them and look after them mhm
instead Abus them and and it's sad
really because it is the hardest earned
money in the world when you've got to
fight Blood and Guts train Blood and
Guts and then to get a took from you
because of skull dugery it's sad I love
the way you just put that the Lambs rule
the Lions it's it's very very true and
even now in the UFC we're seeing a lot
of UFC fighs going through a lawsuit to
get proper pay because of the situation
over there as well and um and yet that
that story of what youve just told there
about you know that first present one of
the very few presents he ever got in his
life probably uh quite a magical thing
to remember I mean as as painful as that
is it's a beautiful memory M and um we
mentioned cus earlier what was cus like
to be around he was wonderful yeah he
was he was a caring
gentleman he lived for the boxers he
lived for the boxing and he took on the
mafia a brave man to take on an
organized crime organization
that still to this day are going strong
MH you know the Mafia the
kostra Michael Frances is coming over on
a tour soon and a lovely man but he was
a mafia Don and they have to rule with
an iron fist they're not going to rule
with kind words they got to rule with
bullets and they've got to rule with
with with with Venom and cus had the
courage to stand up to the dominance of
the mafia with boxing and it I admire
that man so much but he was such a
warm character and just a really really
kind gentleman and it was a
privilege to be with him one of the
greats wasn't he and heed he didn't he
ad Mike he did yeah he legally adopted
Mike he trained Floyd Patterson and he
trained Jose Tes two great champions of
the world Mike was another champion of
the world for him I mean this sport is
built on people like yourself who you
know we all remember the Legends the
Champions but people like you are the
ones who've got to get in there with
them and to give them that Legacy and uh
and that's why I respect like if
anyone's everever got in the ring
they've got my respect for sure but um
one fight that might be happening soon
apparently is I am Mike Tyson versus
fedo emilianenko I don't know if you've
ever heard of fedo he was a heavyweight
MMA a champion one of the greatest of
all time quite like Mike in that he was
an undersized heavyweight but an
explosive puncher uh a Russian actually
and he's 47 I think Mike's 57 Mike's 57
to be 58 in June 30th yeah so they're
thinking about making this apparently
it's all over Twitter I don't know if
it's if it's it's happening for sure but
it seems like they want to make the
fight uh and look I wouldn't be
surprised if it happens in Saudi Arabia
with all of the the fights that they're
putting on Mike is very in with the
Saudis cuz he was helping train Francis
and goru for that last fight so yeah we
might yet see one last goore of Mike
Tyson Mike when he fought Roy Jones
jior Mike has still got a lot left in
him even though he's he's um burnt the
candle of both ends with lifestyle yeah
he's still got a lot left in him you
know cuz when he gets fit that power
that he's got you never lose that power
you might lose the speed to deliver that
punch but Mike has still still got a lot
left to offer do you know the thing that
shocked me about that fight man was uh
Roy Jones obviously has fought quite
recently and he's he sort of always been
in and out of the ring for the last you
know 20 years um you know a lot he went
a lot longer than what people thought he
should have but he fought more recently
and that Mike was the one who looked
like the fresher sharp a guy in that he
he he looked far more dangerous than
that I felt like he was holding back a
little bit I don't I know if you thought
that Roy yeah I thought of course I
think he could have I never believed in
my heart and soul my heart and soul that
Mike could pull his punches but when he
fought Roy Jones Jr he hit Mike Mike hit
Roy with a body punch in the first round
and you could hear the
sickness as that punch landed it hurt
Roy yeah but Mike showed Roy the respect
I'm not saying he carried him but he
didn't go on to hurt him any more than
he needed to he could have hurt him a
lot could have hurt him
look and I respect Mike for that because
Roy is Roy is an incredible champion
four-weight champion of the world you
know to do what he's done in boxing is a
major achievement well he was offering
Tommy Fury a fight recently which would
have been weird um but you know you've
got your likes of aand Holyfield who
fought not long ago uh he fought VTO
Bell uh the MMA guy and his punch
resistance was gone and that's sad to
see for me I I count on
understand how his cornermen or his
trainers didn't see that in sparring and
training you know avander holfield is
one of the greatest champions of all
time take nothing away from the man that
beat him that night MH but it was a
shell of a man that he beats but his
cornermen his trainers would have seen
flaws in aanda in the gym long before
that fight and I don't understand how
how that could happen on on that night
that he he folded with that that first
punch as such his punch resistance
shouldn't have gone that bad for a man
with a granite chin you know one of the
toughest of all time one of the greatest
of all time you know and the real deal
is he used to call absolutely was and a
nice man into the bargain but the same
thing again he's had financial
difficulties maybe that's why they
didn't throw the tow in I think that's
why when they let him fight was for the
money and as I said earlier have to is a
horrible Master he's got a lot of
children he's got grandchildren he's got
Ex-Wives he's got paternity suit he's
got all sorts of um lawsuits and stuff
with money and I don't know his personal
life I know the man he's a lovely lovely
man but when you've got to come back
after what he's achieved in boxing for a
dollar it's sad imagine right you're
going through all of that getting
brutalized by people like Mike Tyson and
and and getting and fighting through
like everything Holyfield came through
and then you know you decide you want to
split with the misses and all of a
sudden you're half the money that you've
been bleeding and blood sweating tears
for it's just like bye like it's it's
ridiculous that my opinion like
it's outrageous I think he's had a few
wives yeah I think he's had a few um
divorce so he's been hit hard into
helmet he's been it hard in the
pocket yeah you know but it SS when
happens but there's no um in boxing like
have soccer there's no testimonial match
you know your last fight really is your
last payday in boxing you might get a
few after the speaking events they might
learn the pockets for a couple of weeks
there not enough to live on yes and look
that's even for the Champions let alone
you know people like yourself who are
just trying to make it work as anywhere
you could so so let's let's go to the
point where you do finish boxing let's
talk about life after boxing for you
what happened next when my boxing career
finished I was in limboland
and um I went into a bit of a depression
for a couple of years because it was
took from me because of a car crash and
um I never understood depression people
used to say to me about depression I
used to say behave yourself until it hit
you and then it's like the Sucker Punch
from hell and I went into limboland for
a couple of years didn't know what to do
with myself cuz everything was box in I
was going to make my fortune boxing I
was going to live the life of Riley
boxing you know and uh it didn't happen
when the accident happened I went
downhill very fast what part of you was
injured from the accident shed my knee
shoted my shoulder shoted my jaw I was
on a coach and a taxi crashed into the
coach I was on and um that Depression
hit me had and then I spoke to my dad
and I said I don't know what to do with
my life dad he said go see Paddy Finn
Paddy Finn's the Irish ex- heavyweight
boxing champion and I used to want to
emulate Paddy he was Irish heavyweight
champion from my old Boxing Club to know
Tony man and Benny braen they trained a
lot of Irish Champions and Paddy was the
he was the man and I wanted to be him
people say who do you want to emulate in
boxing and I idolized Muhammad Ali I
adored Muhammad Ali but I never could
achieve what mahamad Deli achieved but I
I I believe that I had him me to achieve
what Pat Finn achieved winning the
orangish title
and I said I want to emulate Patty Finn
and we became great friends he was older
than me but he helped me so many times
over the years in my career so when he
retired from boxing because he had a
damaged disc in his back I came over to
visit him in Birmingham and I said Paddy
I've been in a bit of a depression for a
couple of years and I don't know what to
do with my life he said well come on
over he said and work for me he said I
teach you the trade of the pub trade he
said I get you some um courses I've done
a bii course British Institute of inke
keeping I've done two mvq courses I left
school with two swiming certificates and
now suddenly I've got a bii certificate
and two MBQ and I done a lensy course
and became the ler of the doubl i p for
petty Finn for two years and then I went
on to get my own pup and um and I was
living the the second bite of the Apple
you know some people don't get one bite
of the Apple I done my first bite a
boxing it didn't work now I've got a
second bite at the Apple and the pob
trade but and the racketeers the
gangsters protection racketeers I took
over the lindos pub in September
97 in July 1998 the racketeers 19th of
July did put a protection Demand on the
pup £500 a week for protection money
about the royalty out of respect up
about the no man out of fear and I said
no the following week the 26th of July
1998 they attacked my Pub 37 of them
with a handgun a shotgun hatchets and
machetes and I took two gunshot
wounds and it was a horrible day in my
life it said in the newspapers the
battle at the Lindhurst made Braveheart
look like a Walt Disney film we had a
Sunday communion on in the function room
the pop was frequented frequented by
xboxers tough guys you know my friends
and I was blessed that they were there
on that day for no other reason than
they fre Ed the
pub and one man in particular a guy
called Steve Dalton he ran at the
bullets I hid behind the wall when the
guy that was doing the shooting stepped
in and was doing the shooting i h behind
the wall I was
terrified you know people ask
me who hurt you the most Mike Tyson or
LX Lewis when a man shot me hurt me the
most because lead hurts Harder Than
Leather and he hurt me the
most but Steve Dalton ran at that man he
ran at the
bullets and I blessed myself I thought
he's going to
die he got shot twice as well but he he
he he was the bravest man I've ever met
him my
life and he put his life on the line for
me for a friend for no financi again
just a friend and uh and incredible but
that day that
day
a band of brothers that day stood
staunch against bully boys nobody likes
a bully I hate bullies with a passion
I've dealt with bullies all my life from
boy to
man and that
day was probably one of the most
horrible days in my
life
but it helped
me in life because different things that
test you help you in life you know and
and that particular day I didn't die but
doesn't kill us makes us
stronger and um can you describe sort of
how it how it sort of unfolded in terms
of where you are when people are coming
through the door and that sort of thing
the armed Response Unit was aware that
day and it still took the police 55
minutes to get to my pup to help me do
you think that that was a there's a
reason for that the particular gang that
had attacked my Pub had been ruling
Birmingham for part of Birmingham for 15
years paty Finn actually burned down two
of his pubs over time you know they're a
well renowned tug gang MH and um I'm not
saying the police were afraid of
them but the police that particular day
wasn't a police
force it was a police fast that day
because they let me down they let my
patrons of my Pub
down
and I
um was badly
wounded I hit behind a wall but a man
called Tim oan who' fought in World War
II an Irish man to fought in the British
Army in World War II he stepped out with
his hands up he said please he said I
can stop this as he stepped out with his
hands up Steve Dalton had been shot I
stepped out from behind the wall to pull
him back in behind the wall and the man
that was doing the
shooting threw the hand gun on the
ground he' emptied three shots from a
handgun a five shot handgun he emptied
three shots two hit tton he was handed a
shotgun a soff shotgun and I've looked
into many men's eyes in the boxing ring
I've looked into many men's eyes on the
door of a nightclub I've never looked
into evil like it in my life he looked
through Tim Oran to shoot me and he
blasted the shotgun and he hit Tim Oran
in the hips and he blasted an old man
that had fought in World War II in a bad
way he took a severe impact with a
shotgun blast a lot of the shotgun pet
then around my
body and the smell of burning
skin was the most horrific smell I'd
ever smelled in my life and it turned
out it was my skin not just him Oran
because the shot on pellets was actually
burning my skin yeah and it was a
stench it was
horrific but so where were you hitting
total shotgun pellets I was wider than
than tin yeah you were a big man and um
he had the hip blast to clean out of him
and um it was a it was a nasty horrific
day and then um my life spiraled out of
control after that because um my
ex-miss she abandoned me she cleared off
with Michael flatly the River Dance SK
it was all over the world's
news because I was a sinking ship
sinking pretty fast Michael flatly of of
all people I don't for people who don't
know he was a very famous dancer back he
was the biggest star of Irish Danon of
all time he was earning a million pounds
a week listen I nearly cleared off with
him myself to tell you the truth you
know but um they said I wasn't a fit and
proper
person to run a pup because of what had
happened I was the one that was attacked
so they were trying to evict me right
now I'd already been through an eviction
not my family was evicted when I was a
child in Dublin mhm you know so I know
about
evictions and they were trying to evict
me from the purpose I had to fight them
to trying to hold on to the roof over my
head I had to fight with Lisa my ex to
hold on to a roof that I had in irand
property that I had in Island oh cuz she
was in there she was in the house and I
yeah and then to add insult of injury I
was charged with attempted murder and
all I done was defend myself so now I'm
fighting on three
fronts and I ran out of money I was
selling everything I had to pay for
legal fees yeah
and I saw my car saw my watched and my M
got me from my 18th birthday my ring and
my dad got me from my 21st I sold
everything I had to pay legal fees what
was being done to me was an injustice
all I done was defend myself and I do
the same again today I defend myself
so how attempted murder because that
particular day there was a lot of people
wounded but I was the only one that was
charged my door man Danny Brown he was
charged but the charges were dropped
against him and I was the only one that
was charged so none of the gang members
no and a lot of them were B cled up and
scarves on their faces and everything
else but um I beat the charges headlines
in the newspaper justice
prevails I beat the brewery I kept my my
pop but it was never the same again
after
that scared to come down on my house in
Island I got that as well but ended up
selling it cheap so I lost even though I
won on all three fronts I lost but the
sad thing what I had to do to fight was
at to turn to
crime and um I regreted to this day
shamed of myself that I did it I'd never
been in trouble in my life before like I
said earlier in the interview the only
time I saw my dad cry was when I was
sent to only time I saw him cry was when
his daddy died and when I got sent to
prison I watched him cry and um but my
life went out of control and uh what
kind of crime was it that you turned to
what happened was there was a guy used
to frequent the pup and um he was
involved in stolen cars and he asked
could he pack stolen cars on my car pack
of my pup at that time I was so
desperate for money he could have parked
tanks on my car P how wouldn't it care I
just needed the money I was paying legal
face hand over fist and it was
so
hard to just keep paying out legal fees
had an absis burst in my bell with the
stress I was going through and I
collapsed
twice with the pain of the apps's poison
I could have got sep to me I could have
died the pain that went through my body
with the poison from the absis burst of
my bowel I collapsed twice and um I was
very lucky to survive the thing that's
hit me is as far as I'm aware you're not
the one stealing the cars I was the one
that allowed them to be parked on my car
park so is that what they got you on
yeah they got it on a conspiracy right
so you were a part of the operation I'm
ashamed to say yes I'm ashamed to say
how long did they give you I originally
got two and a half years but because I'd
exposed the West Midlands
police they increased my sentence they
tried to increase it the 70 increased it
the four ended up serving 2 years but
while I was into the prison I saved the
man's life and and I came out a better
person how did that happen one of the
prison officers took a heart attack and
when I was a kid I was in the St John's
ambulance Brigade so I know a little bit
about first aid I attended the man I set
off the alarm the security um response
team got the man to the hospital and he
survived I got accommodation from the
Governor I was just happy to save the
man's life he didn't put me in prison he
was there to supervise my stay yeah you
know I put myself in prison but doing
what I'd done I'm ashamed of what i'
done but while I was in there I made the
best of it I came out a better person
than what I went in did you not have any
issues with the screws or anything like
that no no no had a little bit of an
issue with bully boys in the prison oh
really yeah you know there's a little
bit of uh
a little bit of gang Warfare in and I
was in three different prisons and like
why three did they move you like
deliberately because of that or no you
get moved for one reason or another you
know but bully boys tend to act in in
gangs yeah you know they they're really
yellow and what do bananas come in in a
bunch and that's where the bullies are
as
well you know they come in packs pack
animals
and I I diffuse the few of the bully
Boys in prison same as had defused the
few of the bully boys outside of prison
and no one likes a bully but when um
when I came out of prison I wanted to to
to turn my life around I made to come
back into boxing I became Jer boxery and
not Jer convict it redeemed myself My
Daddy's Eyes which I was so proud of and
then I met a friend um man called Ken
purchas and another friend a man called
Charlie hail and they were running after
it in the speaking events and they said
uh we're going to do a dinner with Joe
frasia Joe one of the greatest
heavyweight champions of all time and um
I I I'd spad Mike for the Fraser fight
as far as I remember but I knew Marvis
anyway I knew was with Mike at the time
when he fought Marvis and
um I went to the dinner and I got to
share the top table with Joe Frasier I
got to share the top table with Mar
sitting beside them Steve Collins Alan
Mina Charlie mgy John H Tracy great
Champions I'm sitting on the table with
this illustrious company and I was so
honored and humbled to be at the top
table did I help your self-esteem after
feeling like and that did it what
yeah in the acknowledgement in my book I
think Ken purchas and Charlie Hill first
two they gave me a
chance no one else gave me a chance
and when I was at the dinner I met Cass
pennant I know who Cass was because my
nephew Tom he's a West Ham fan and I
knew who Cass was he the Bookman and I
said to Cass it's good to meet
you you might write a book about me half
joke and half hold and Earnest and he
said let me listen to what you got to
say
tonight and he said if it's good we'll
talk at 5 minutes I got as much as I
possibly could in in 5 minutes trying to
impress this man Cas pant wanting him to
take an interest in me I was directing
everything at him anyway afterwards I
went over and I spoke to him and he said
you're an interesting character he said
if we can get Mike Tyson involved he
said the might be a booking you come to
my office tomorrow I went to his office
on Tottenham Court Road the next day and
we found mik Mike was in Brazil and I
found Mike I said Mike this man might do
a book about me will you help and Mike
come on to the phone to Cass and he said
to Cass this is fact anything for my
brother
Joe and Mike agreed to come over launch
the book he agreed to do the forward for
the book he brought Canary wolf to a
standstill thousands and thousands and
thousands of people in Canary WF when
Mike launched my book in 2005 I know
everybody was there for Mike
but Mike was there for
me that's such a SP oh incredible
incredible several world champions in
attendance Charlie mgy uh Alan Mina Paul
silky Jones Brian London was there um
loads of great champions in attendance
Barry mcgan I got the photographs on my
phone queued queued with his son Shane
with the ordinary people and I got the
photographs I got the photographs on my
phone my Tyson's jumped up Barry mcgan
Shane was standing beside his daddy
Barry queued with the normal people and
Mike was in order Barry mcgan was there
and Barry came around the table Mike
summons him around I got all the
photographs I'll show you afterwards
Mike summons him around the table they
embraced and Barry mcgan standing there
and Mike's going yo Barry mcgan what are
you queuing for but the man is humble
anyway afterwards I'm talking to Shane
Shane go Shane was 16 at the time he
said that's just my dad I said your dad
is Barry mcgan one of the greatest feder
Champions Islands ever produced one of
the greatest world champions of all time
they had a private audience back in the
hotel in in Park Lane Mike and Barry and
Shane and it was incredible but Barry I
used to tell Mike Tyson loves you dearly
admires you so much and Barry used to
laugh I said no I'm telling you and then
when that day he saw it with his own
eyes I said the Barry I told you I told
you didn't I and he laughed but
when Cass published my
book he had a movie made about his life
called Cass and he gave me a part in the
movie I played the landlord of the
britania
pub ironic yes ironic yeah not that I'm
any good of an actor just it was an easy
part to play after running a pob and
um I uh met tamama Hassan the actor on
the film
set big star and he said Joe you got a
great presence on screen he said to your
fancy an acting career my agent could do
something with you I said I've acted my
way through a boxing career I'll give it
a go I love it so he introduced me to
his agent his agent said there's a a
part in a film called Sherlock Holmes
and they're looking for a character
called mcmurder to fight Robert Downey
Jr do you want to go for the part I said
yeah give it a go so I went along done
the audition the casting agent said look
into the camera lens give an
intimidating stair say this line so I
looked into the camera lens gave the
intimidating stair said the line that
went wow you've got an amazing
intimidating stare I said I have to look
into the eyes of Mike Tyson and Lenox
Lewis to try and intimidate them if I
can intimidate them I can intimidate you
easy enough and we got the part I went
along to the read through in clar's
hotel in London me and my friend Richard
Grimes he drove me down and we're
sitting in the big Lounge suite at a
clarous hotel my name plate Joe Eagan
next to Jude Law Robert Downey Jr Rael
McAdams Eddie Marson all the stars of of
of the film all the hierarchy of Warner
Brothers I'm sitting opposite guy Richie
and Joel Sila the CEO of Warner Brothers
and guy said Joe I've been trying to get
you in one of my films for a long time I
said you're joking and Robert Downey Jr
leaned in in front of my friend Richard
Grimes and he said Joe you come with a
fearsome reputation I couldn't believe
that these people even knew me but they
knew me through Mike Tyson and I was so
I was so shocked anyway we traveled in
the minib buus to do the practice fight
the guy said how are things Joe I said
things are okay guy I'm making ends meat
he says your agent told you much again
for the fight scene as a guy never even
asked I'm just honored to be in your
film when he told me it was more than I
got any of my professional fights I was
deadly serious as that guy for that
money as a Robert Downey junr can really
hit me you can kick me as well if you
want to and he took a fit of laughing he
said Joe I don't want you be beaten up
as a guy I've been beating up for a lot
less I'll do a few weeks in hospital for
that money anyway I didn't have to do
the fight scene he put me in the prison
scene that wasn't in the script uhhuh
and I get called Big Joe by an Academy
Award winner in a Warner Brothers movie
directed by Guy Richie and my mom was so
proud she never wanted me to box Brian
no mother wants to see I saw him being
beaten up she never wanted me the box
but you saw me getting killed and
beating up in filmed many many time and
she she didn't mind because she knew it
wasn't real yeah you know and it made me
feel so good because I I'd like to think
that my boxing made my dad proud and my
films made my M proud and as I said
earlier in the interview it's all you
want to do in life is do your parents
proud and I hope I did absolutely man
there's no doubt in anyone's mind of
after hearing this story the parts are
getting bigger with experience I
recently done a film um a while back the
last film I done just before my mom d
died I did prize fighter with Russell
Crow and he calls me Joe in the film I
actually haven't seen the film and he
calls me Joe another Academy Award
winner calling me by my own name so I
get called my own name in two films by
two Academy Award winners the parts are
getting bigger with experience I get to
play the gangster or the tough guy you
know I've had to live the life of a
tough guy and but when I met you the
other nightmare I took one look I
thought well he looks like the bad guy
in the movie doesn't he that's the
that's that's the that's I get you know
and they're easy parts to play because
I've had to live that life of a tough
guy standing on the doors work in
security you know boxing I've had to
live that life you know I haven't had to
do any sort of testing acting because I
haven't had to play anything other than
what I've had to living life tough guy
Russell Crow is a big name I mean
powerful powerful name and acting
Gladiator Maximus is one of my favorite
films but I loved him in in most of his
films that he done but when he done the
Cinderella Man incredible film
incredible glad you are so good oh
brilliant but the thing is my dream can
I do an impression for you g cor ready
yeah father to a murdered son husband to
a murdered wife and I will have my
Vengeance in this life or the next very
good there you go very get me in the
next one very very good do you know what
I Maximus desus Meridius unbelievable
I've got a few more questions for you go
ahead so I want to ask you uh about the
first time you've ever been dropped my
dad used to call me for my runs in the
morning I never liked the running and my
dad used to call me to go running in the
morning the early hours of the morning
and he said oh no dad I don't I don't
want to go out running drag yourself out
of bed son it's like dragging yourself
off the deck when you get put down I
said no one's going to put me down Dad
no one's going to put me down my Chin's
Granite my legs are
strong I've been put onto the ropes a
few times but I've never been put flat
on my back the first time I was put flat
on my back in 1987 in the Acropolis
games I'm in the
semi-finals and i' had two hard fights
to get to the
semi-finals and my left eye was
damaged and had a goal in the first
round before my eye completely closed
and in the second round the Greek hit me
with a punch I didn't see the punch
coming I didn't feel the punch I'm flat
on my back and I'm lying on my back and
I'm doing this I'm looking for my bed
sheets I'm asleep but I'm looking
looking for my bed sheet wow my two
cornerman Mickey Hawkins and jenry
Hannah they thought I was calling them
into the ring I wasn't I'm on my back in
bed I'm asleep I turn on to my side my
left eyes completely closed my right
eyes open and I see the referee go five
so from the time I was hit to the time I
fell to the time I'm lying on my back to
the time I'm pulling my bed sheet over
me to the time I see the referee it's 15
seconds I'm
asleep I thought oh my God I'm on the
deck here
I got to my feet the two cornermen were
in the ring I fell into their arms I got
stopped on my feet the man that beat me
went to get the gold medal so I lost to
the eventual gold medalist but I
remember phing my dad I said dad I
wanton a bronze medal he said Well Done
son I said dad remember you told me
about dragging myself out of bed in the
morning is like dragging yourself off
the deck he said did you get deck son I
said I did that I got decked got put
down in round two but I got to my feet
dad I got beat on my feet but it was
exactly like you described it was like
being asleep in
ped and I never felt the
punch people ask me about the hardest
punch I've ever been
hit the hardest punch I ever got hit was
by Victor Cordova I was sping in Mr
Eastwood gym in Belfast and he was the
Panamanian super middleweight champion
of the world and they wanted him to
impress in front of the camera for a
title fight in Belfast and they got me
into sparring with him to throw he was
throwing combinations to show his
Brilliance and he hit me an uppercut and
he caught me on the tip of my nose and
they say you can kill a man by driving
the bone of the nose I've heard that
before this is what they say and um I
guess it's not true cuz you're still
here like it hurt me that much the pain
went from my nose to my ankles the blood
went everywhere my two eyes closed and I
was so badly hurt with that one punch
Mike hit me with a lot of hurtful
punches Lenox Lewis hit me with a lot of
hurtful punches and a lot of Fighters
over the years have hit me with a lot of
hurtful punches but that one punch I
remember that hurt the most but the one
that actually put me flat on my back I
never felt it strange isn't it it's this
they say it's the ones you don't see I
guess that often are the ones that drop
people yeah of all the people you've met
in this life who was it that helped you
the
most
o I've had a lot of people help me in my
life but there's a there's a particular
man
um man called John honor we got way back
he raised my brother when they were kids
and um him and his business partner John
has a company called Welsh civils and
his business partner Ally to have wel
civils Alli has a a jewelry shop as well
called lest bullion that was the sign in
the background of of the thing yeah them
them two in particular at this stage of
my life have been of breath of fresh air
mhh
because
the last few years have been
hard yeah
very very hard respect to that mate um
in terms of the other side of the coin
who would you saying looking back in
life was the one that let you down the
most the Irish
government they let me down to let my
family
down me and my brother used to chop
sticks as kids we used to buy a bag of
logs and we used to get the inner tube
of a car and we used to cut the inner
tube of a car across to make a big
elastic
band and we used to get a bag of logs
and we used to chop the logs into
sticks and we used to sell the 150 bag
of logs for £750 bundles of
sticks and we used to do it from the
back Garden of our Council
house
anyway somebody reported two boys
working 12 13 13 14 making money from
the back of a council house and the the
Dublin Corporation the council at the
time put the rent up to maximum rent and
they backdated It 2 years and they said
my family owed £6,000 in the
re I was away boxing for Ireland away
boxing for for Dublin or a boxing anyway
in
Denmark and while I was away Dublin
Council Corporation evicted my family
there was a 4- day
Siege my mom cut her wrists and stuck a
knife on her
stomach she tried to kill
herself which was
horrific my dad fought the bers off for
4 days and eventually after 4 days the
Irish police force the GU your a corner
they were called in my grandfather was a
sergeant in the Irish police force at
one stage of his life he was a policeman
all his life so my dad expected the G
and they came out of the
house and they gave the house up I
didn't even know this was going on I'm
away boxing in Denmark in hburg and
Copenhagen as a young boy I didn't know
this was going
on so when I'm ringing home after my
fights I couldn't get an answer on the
phone so I rang my nana and my nana
broke down crying she said your mom's
okay she
okay she said your mom tried to kill
herself I said no
oh my mom wouldn't do that anyway when I
got picked up at Dublin Airport I got
dropped at the bottom of my
road the TD which is like an MP in the
Irish government Shawn Moore he was
fighting for my family it was wrong what
they were doing to my family it was
wrong on all levels right he fought for
the family they actually named the road
sha Mo Ro after
him
and the coach the mini stopped me at the
bottom of my road on my sports bag on my
suitcase and I ran that
road and when I came into view of my
family home 6 Prem and Grove my dad
sitting outside on a rocking chair all
my family's belongings all on the street
all my boxing trophies were smashed the
Bays have smashed my boxing
trophies and it was wrong on every level
what they did to my family on that house
in estate it didn't need to come to that
it didn't need to come to that to made
an example of my
family that Council years later was
exposed for
corruption that housing estate that that
house was on that was the housing estate
that my auntie lived on that I went on
to with Mike Tyson I walked onto that
housing estate all them years later with
Mike
Tyson
and that was something that should never
have happened
it broke a
family and it was wrong it didn't need
to come to
that that's so powerful that
me you've came through so much it's
[Music]
unbelievable it's all right
mate take your time bro
I wasn't
there are you beating yourself up cuz
you wasn't there
yeah mate you were just a kid you didn't
even know and I bet you they didn't tell
you for that reason cuz they wouldn't
have wanted to worry you when you were
out trying to make a better life for
yourself and you still sent money home
to
them so you did everything you could
have
done
it's out of order that like that's
disgraceful that they did that them
where about in Island was this
Dublin Rings
end six bman
Grove my younger brothers and sisters
had to enure that my
mom fromont Page News can carry down a
stretcher for first floor window other
taking a knif on
herself
no wonder I when I said to you earlier
on I had a heart heart heart
life yes
bro the boxer ring was safe for me yeah
and I know if this John Fury fight comes
off it's not going to phase me know what
I've been through in my life
nothing can f face me but I hope you get
it man because you deserve it you
deserve your
moment but you've done really well you
know you should be proud of yourself I
hope you are after everything you've
been through to achieve all that I
haven't told you hardly anything of what
I've had to endure in life you know I've
had battles in New York I've had battles
in Belfast I've had battles in Dublin
I've had battles in Birmingham I've had
battles in London I've had batt all my
life cuz as I said to you earlier on not
about the royalty out of respect about
the know man out of fear I can't do it I
won't do it and that's the sh that I
wear fear face everything and
Rise I won't forget everything and run I
face it and Rise
yes I love
that well done man honestly I love the
I'm sorry I'm sorry don't worry don't
apologize I Cry we're grateful
for your story everyone who's listening
right now like Mike Tyson said Joo
you're always
crying do you know Mike Tyson loves a
good cry as well though so he's CRI
cries me and him have cried together
yeah me and him have cried together oh
really yeah yeah he hurt me with his
punches and I hurt his
knuckles you know when Mike Tyson talks
about Muhammad Ali oh yeah that's when
he when I watch him go when he talks
about how great Muhammad Ali was to me
the greatest of all time like he says Go
goat the greatest of all time I met the
man four times I went to his house in
Michigan who's that Muhammad Ali really
I went to his house in Michigan I met
him at his home Al Capone used to own
the house I've been in his house I've
been in his home with him and his wife
got rest him before he died I met him in
Louisville I met him with his brother I
met him in Washington DC when when Lela
boxed she fought the IR she fought the
Irish girl Aon TOA and I bet him I met
him in New York Mike I met him on four
occasions to be in the presence of
greatness not just the greatest man to
enter a boxing ring one of the greatest
men to enter this world boxing was
privileged to have him he could have
turned his hand to Baseball American
football basketball he was just a
supreme athlete boxing was privileged to
have him and he was like I said one of
the greatest human
beings ever he's up there with the the
the the greatest what was he like when
you met him beautiful yeah beautiful to
talk
to to be in the presence of it was
incredible what was Mike like around him
cuz
Mike Mike was in all of him I used to do
an Ali Shuffle as a tribute to Muhammad
Ali long before I ever met him my dad
met him first my Dad met him at the um
Steve Collins fight when Steve Collins
fought I it was Rachel Johnson and Steve
for him and my my brother-in-law the
policeman in New York got them ticket
and my dad my sister my nephew Tom would
have been three or four at the time and
he he he ran through the feet or the
legs of the bodyguards and my dad was
trying to stop the bodyguards and they
and Muhammad Ali would no and Muhammad
Ali picked up my nephew Tom I think he
was three and my dad Stood Beside
Muhammad Ali holding my nephew Tom my
sister's boy and I used to Envy my dad
and he was to Envy Tom Tom was too young
to understand who he was holding who was
holding him up yeah but I used to eny my
dad that he met Muhammad Ali before me
yeah but when I met him on four
occasions just in total awe just in
total awe and even now talking about it
it still gives me one of the greatest
feelings that I've ever had to have met
that man well what he went through I
mean well I did a bit of like research
cuz he was a bit before my time and and
when I looked into him saying you know
how he used to say look I I won you lot
of go gold medal and I can't even eat
and and going to the same restaurants as
all you lot because of the segregation
that's going on you won't even call me
by the name that I'm asking you to call
you w't show me that respect after I've
won this country a gold medal now I'm
world champion and you want me to go and
die for your causes it was um it was
disgraceful the way he was treated I'll
tell you a story about aand holifield I
did a dinner with him in
Spain and they asked Dand holifield a
question what it was like winning his
first world title I think he won the
world Cruiserweight title M and he said
where he lived in Georgia there was a
club that he wasn't allowed to go into
because of his color mhm and he said he
used the queue to try to get in and when
he get to the front of the queue they
would turn him
away and I'm sitting in the dinner in
Spain in front of an audience of 800
people thousand people M and he said
when I won the world title for the first
time he said I didn't even have the
queue to get into that nightclub
and I thought that's what it meant
because they wouldn't allow him in
before even with his Olympic bronze
medal and when he won the world title he
said I didn't even have the queue get
into that nightclub and I just thought
that's not that long ago it isn't
exactly you know and racism is a
horrific horrible thing I've experienced
racism the same people that hate black
people that hate Asian people also hate
the IR Irish people MH that's one thing
we don't do as as an Irish Nation we
don't do racism we fight each other have
some great punch ups with my two
brothers you know but that's sibling
rivalry yeah but we don't fight against
the man because of his color you know
and it's horrific horrific horrible
racism it shouldn't be listen men and
women died in the world wars against
Fascism and racism then people would
roll over in their graves of racists
would they get away what what these
people died fighting
against you mentioned uh about the story
of Muhammad Ali I've actually recently
interviewed his granson who's now making
a go of boxing I don't know if you know
that I think it's called Nik um Niko Ali
Walsh um he's one of Muhammad Ali's
daughters Sons okay and he's a good
boxer so yeah there's still uh still
left life left in the bloodline uh so
we'll see what happens with the young
lad it's it's an incredible act for the
man to have to follow the pressures on
his shoulders imagine you know it's like
any any Champion sibling to to to
perform you know after the parents
setting president of becoming a champion
yeah cuz Lea was a hell of a champion as
well incredible fighter when he beat
Erin toor that night in Washington DC it
was on the uh Tyson McBride undercard
yeah and um eron TOA of Irish descent
gave a great performance for three
rounds but Leela's class was just too
much for her massive and athletic wasn't
you incredible fighter but some of these
some of these great Champions children
like there was uh Jackie Frasier Hyde
Joe Fraser's da daughter uh Le Ali
mhammad Ali's daughter did you see the
the the Netflix show uh they they've got
one called Untold no the there's a
female boxer who ended up fighting Lea
she fought on an undercard of a my Tyson
undercard this woman
um I'm I'm going to have to Google that
right now so I know what the hell I'm
talking about um you know when I sat in
the Green Room filming Sherlock Holmes
Rachel McAdams I'm sitting in the green
room with Rachel McAdams and she said
Joe you used the box I said a long time
ago Rachel she said I'm reading a boxing
script at the moment she's filming
Sherlock Holmes I said are you she said
yeah I said what's a called she said
southp I said is it good she said very
good two years later she won the Academy
Award for it but I sat in the green room
talking to her about that have you SE so
it's Christy Martin they made oh great
fighter yeah she what a she was one of
the
early women champ oh she's a Pioneer
yeah but there was also the English girl
um good friend of mine J couch yeah Jane
said president on on on female she beat
the British boxing Board of control for
a license you know an incredible fighter
but these women listen the suffrage Edge
did what they did and suffered what they
suffered for equal rights for women
women are flying a planes women are
driving tanks women are electricians A
Woman's Place isn't just in the kitchen
that's old school women can do every bid
as good a job in any field and given the
chance to as a man you know we had there
different strengths there you know so
they're not going to be the powerlifting
Champions like the men but they can
still live powerful weights they're not
going to
be in certain Sports as good as the men
but the every right to compete and
boxing is just a sport that they right
to compete in the suff Jets did what
they did for equal rights for women and
some of these women fights see the 2012
Olympics the best part of the 2012
Olympics was when nickol Adams won that
gold medal and was the first female gold
medalist of all time and her smile lit
up yeah lit up the TV screen lit up the
room lit up the world she was incredible
the first female gold medist and now
you've got some of these women that
fights the Irish girl Katie Taylor I bet
you love her I know I dad Peter very
well I know Katie since she's a little
girl I used to train with Peter oh
really and I remember KY looking through
the ropes as a little girl when I sped
with her dad her dad was a great
heavyweight hard tough man you know
explains where she gets it from then
bulletproof she's incredible she's had a
rivalry with that English girl the last
two fights the English girl won the
first one ktie won the second fight
there's got to be a trilogy there you
know there has to be a Trilogy you know
and some of these trilogies are great
look at the atoro GTI mcky War Trilogy
you know incredible um I'm going to ask
you now the final question that I like
to ask everyone I've asked a lot of big
famous people this one and I'm
interested to know what yours is is how
would you like to be
remembered as a nice
guy that's how I want to be
remembered as a nice guy I mean you you
look quite intimidating but you are a
very nice guy mate so you've definitely
nailed that that's what I want to be by
people to say Joe Ean what a nice guy
yeah well you've been incredibly
respectful through everything you've
said including talking about John Fury
despite wanting to make that fight
happen I really hope it happens for you
mate after everything you've been
through it would be lovely to see you
and Big John put on a a show for the
fans and I know John said a lot of
things in the in the past now he's got
his opponent he's got Misfits ready to
make him an offer and the crowd would
love to see it so I hope it happens for
you man hope Ms and KSI and misfits
makes it happen you know I'm sure which
you help briyan it can happen and we'll
we'll do a good job on the night oh man
I'm looking forward to it we'll do a
good job on the night yeah but when it's
over me and jonan brace would shake
hands and the best man will win on the
night I'm hoping it's me you know I'm
sure John he would be hoping it's him
we'll see yeah we'll see but like you
said earlier on the question I just want
to be remembered as a nice guy I won't I
won't slander or slate
anybody
well that was a very emotional and uh
interesting conversation M thanks for
coming I really appreciate it was lovely
meeting you the other night I think when
when I met you said I will'll do a
podcast you didn't think I would call
you up so quickly you're a man of your
word I did tell you and you know
something if a person has hasn't got the
word it's sad really well we had we had
a chat and you said oh I'll get you in
my don't worry I said I'm not a
bullshitter no I'll see you you stood
and a man of me word yeah man of your
word you know and that's that's an
admirable thing to have to have your
word
you know well thank you for this now my
pleasure we we'll wrap it up there that
was Big Joe Eagan on the true Joy
podcast don't forget to like the video
subscribe and we'll see you on the next
one
[Music]
cheers